thank you very much
to say something about semi-structured
law
anomaly detection I'm marching I'm a
data science team leader I've secured in
Poznan office I'm now almost four years
working for that company in
cybersecurity I'm working as a data
scientist but before I was back-end
developer and I also had a career in in
the scientific world I was a researcher
so I'm not only interested in data
science data analysis but I'm also
interesting in bioinformatics maybe some
of you know the company but I will say a
few words about it we are probably the
biggest cyber security company in the
Europe we operate in many countries we
have almost 30 offices and 1,700 workers
and to summarize I will say you
something about the security and log
data and maybe give you very short
introduction to history of natural
language processing then I will speak
about word embeddings and give you a
snapshot how to normalize or find rules
for data normalization and at the end I
will tell you something how to detect
anomalies with data and betting's
so to give you a glimpse how our
products try to to find hackers in our
in already when they are operating in
organization I will just show you a few
slides
what is the pipeline that how we gather
data so on our you know in the
organization and client we have deployed
sensors that sends logs basically so
text data we call them events and they
send it to our back-end in the backend
we have many different machine learning
statistical analysis of that events and
they we try to generate anomalies and
those anomalies have later
viewed by our fret hunters so we can
have some degree of false positives and
human will confirm that something is
very malicious and we should inform our
client about hacking activity and we
promise to give such a information
directly and within 30 minutes from the
detection of such malicious activity so
what actually is semi-structured log
data in natural text if you read books I
would call it unstructured because we
have just flow of words there is a
semantic and certainty syntactic meaning
but when we talk about logs usually
there is some kind of text it can be
either HTTP logs from Apache server that
has some structure it is like timestamp
there is may be error or warning and
there is a message containing some
information so sometimes it has schema
but usually it this schema can change so
we we speak about text data usually a
JSON and it's it's really in the lock
context it's a time sequence and that
schema can be flexible over time there
can be additional fields additional
meanings different data types they can
be nested structures they can be lists
so it's not as in in in sequel databases
that you have a big table and you can
you can say what is the scheme at the
beginning we rather the derive schema on
the fly when the data arrives and in
this in the pipeline I just showed you
it's usually big volumes of data we
process millions and billions of events
of such type and in the less like
further talk I will usually just give
you a sample of process creation event
so we can say which process started
which process so we have parent process
and child process may be path of that
and file name and Shawanna and
of the file and so on so out of this
this events we could actually build a
process tree to recover which process
spawned which process and we would like
to find anomalies in such process tree
actually in the in the chains so we
believe that if there is a normally in
such a chain of execution it might be
some malicious activity an Ahmadi
doesn't mean a malicious but but we
believe it's correlated and something
that usually people forget with this is
a product that people like organization
pay so so when you have some CPU RAM and
latency restrictions so we try to do
this anomaly detection with restrictions
of our our resources so we would like to
have a more or less reasonable cost of
that processing if you imagine that we
process billions of events ok so let's
talk how we can do that on a multi
detection if we take a look on the
history and NLP at the beginning that
was probably experts writing some hands
write handwritten rules later they will
simple statistical models maybe engrams
with more advanced machine learning but
later we have big advantage of recurrent
neural networks and especially long
shoten memory cells and different
architectures that allows natural
language processing to to develop
quickly so nowadays we have this new
development that is transformer or
attention in other words and we have
very huge models train of gigabytes of
text and different architectures from
from top companies like Google or
Facebook or other big companies so they
are massive and probably that could be
good start to work with but this is
usually trained on natural language so
we cannot do this we cannot
take this for example birth model and
and do transfer learning because it's
usually trained on English and we have
log date so we we could start from the
beginning build a baseline model to
compare it because we would like to have
maybe simple model is good enough with
the resources that we have
so with part of words approach you
usually take the event and then encode
what kind of program is executed within
this even but in such a way you can
build either one hot encoding count
factors or inverse the different way of
counting the the events but anyway you
get huge matrix that is usually sparse
so we have huge feature vector with
hundreds of thousands of columns and and
then easily you get this curse of tiny
mention a little problem and there are
other problems like if you take just is
the program in the event usually you
lose the order of the of the execution
and it's important is the Explorer
calling CMD or CMD calling Explorer of
course you can use it and Gramps but
then this this feature matrix is even
bigger and even more sparse and actually
this this is not the biggest problem the
biggest problem is that similar programs
of different versions of the same
program will be different features in
that matrix so also in our our context
of machine learning in cybersecurity the
data patterns changes to their updates
of programs everyday Windows updates new
versions of programs new new companies
coming to the to the product also we we
are working in an agile way so we
develop our sensors they send different
data different schema can be applied to
our data and just just few shots how
variable the data can be for example if
if there is a directory that contains a
date
there is already like hundreds of
versions of that you can right date in
many ways so it's even more programs has
versions so usually like you can have
version of.net or database or Java or
you can just have a localization
so like PL directories or PL code in the
name of the program even that that's not
the best not the worst case the worst
case is actually that some programs has
random components of some directories
has no random components like you IDs or
user IDs or temp directories or
installation is to know the automatic
they get random digit at the end called
MS I get some kind of hex middle in the
name so that creates a huge world in
balance so we can imagine that you have
path route of the of the directory like
system 32 is very common to many files
but then this run of programs or
directories that has this random
component is just like single event in
such a such a stream so we tried to use
word embeddings to fight these problems
to find similar to encode words into
into vectors that have some meaning of
similarity so first of all we need to
define what is the word actually in the
log data so in our case when we talk
about program even like new process
events we could for example split by
slash and then have words as directories
and file names or program names and then
for each of that words we would like to
assign to it and not a 1 that means of 0
that it exists or not but we would like
to assign a vector of loads of real
numbers to have the representation in
some continuous kind of way
so we
if that each that's a column could
represent some abstract meaning like
color car is it animal is it machine is
it human is it male or female and so on
and what is even more important in
natural language there is assumption
that the word meaning actually can be
defined by the neighborhood context of
the world so if the word is in the same
context it probably means the same so
this is very good for our use case that
if we have a version of the program like
Java directory then if we have other
version of that it probably will have
very similar neighborhood and it at the
end will the embedding will create very
similar vector so we use this this
concept to create the embeddings but
then because we have this dis random
components that are huge and this huge
imbalance of the words we actually tried
to normalize our data set to know to
lower down the memory usage or CPU usage
and we could actually use the initial
embedding on subset of data because it's
very good to find the like if something
is random it will be many times on many
machines visible but then in the final
and bending we could use those
normalization rules on the whole set and
then train the final model and on the
whole set so that we will at the end to
push it through the anomaly detection
energy okay so we need to create
neighborhood or the sentence in natural
language because the sentence definition
actually force what is similar and what
is not similar so in our case I there
are many options but for one option is
that for example we take just a path of
the of the child process then the file
name of the process of child process and
then for example parent
finally so we would like to have okay
that we believe that if the programs are
stored in the same localization then
they are similar but they are also
similar if they are executed by similar
same parent processing and you can see
that there are many examples with with
that kind of I call them pathological
random parts so they can be hided a
version of some parts of the of the of
the of the world as random that can be
UUID or I don't fight for quick version
and so on so platform and we try
different word embeddings but we find
out that the first text is slightly
better than the word to vac this is
because it also takes into account the
engrams of characters of the words so we
took for the for the for the project we
took a sample of 22 million role events
and then we created such sentences that
I described it was more than half
million but you can see that this this
actually has like almost every sentence
has some random kind of part because
there is about half million of unique
words in that vocabulary
okay but it actually worked so Python is
similar to different petrol versions or
JDK is is similar to different JDK
folders with different versions core
similarity can change but more or less
it is able to cluster the data in the in
the desired man
so we then look under under clusters we
do the DB scan clustering and project it
with Disney so you can see the big
clusters of some temp directories or the
MSI as I already showed you some Java on
this cold digits you IDs and so on so
so we then try to generate normalization
rules or rag ex rules to just minimize
the vocabulary size as I already told
you we did DBS can do with cosine
distance and then try to find patterns
and this is rather trivial approach for
each cluster we group the words by the
length then for each group we try to
detect conserved part of the letters of
characters and then for the rest we try
to find a pattern so for example here is
hexadecimal kind of options so we can
create easily the reg X rule that there
is MSI three hexes dot TMP and so on all
four hexes and that are other examples
of the rules of ten directories or
program names but for example this one
on the right bottom is pretty funny
it is very general it actually matches
all the programs that has eight
characters dot three characters so we
had to curated this list manually so so
that very general rules shall not apply
to the at the end okay so we generated
we normalized the the vocabulary and we
were able with about thirty rules to
squeeze the vocabulary seven times so
now it's about seventy five thousand of
unique words and seventeen hundred
thousand unique sentence so it's it's
it's I think it's it's beneficial to do
that in our context okay let's come back
to the initial program we wanted to find
the anomalies in process creation chains
so for example let's say PowerShell
called PowerShell could be animali in
the context of like CMD + W gate and
Explorer
so how do how to find such anomalies
there are many different ways but we
tried auto-encoder model so it's like we
try to it is very similar to compression
so we try to compress some set of values
into smaller set and then decompress it
so it's more or less like loosely
compression so when you put a it's a
representation of the words or the
vectors represented that represent that
such words we would like to recover that
vector and if there is let's say random
and seen a combination of words the
reconstruction error at the end would be
big so that you will get something
something wrong basically so we believe
that for the assumption for auto-encoder
is that we would like to overfeed so
that it will learn the patterns that
were in the training set but when you
pass new data that was never seen the
reconstruction error should be big and
we actually applied it to two LST
recurrent autorecover and we use GU
cells because they're just a little bit
faster so we had three levels for encode
and three layers for decoder and
actually this is basically proof of
concept that it works so for the
training set is the reconstruction error
is below zero point zero zero four in
our case so it's this blue class but
when we randomly shifted all the words
in such a sequence of process creation
chains the reconstruction error was high
so we actually proven that this auto
encoder could be used as some kind of
anomaly detection so in practice in
production we probably would put the
threshold at the end of this region here
so
such such points would be investigated
by our Fred Huntersville and maybe with
additional information from other events
it will be enough to justify there was
some malicious activity okay so to sum
up I have told you something about the
word embeddings for the log that we
process I showed you simple way to
generate rules based on clustering and
then at the end I showed you some
concept how to use auto encoder to find
anomalies in such space and I would like
to thank my team especially Michael Burt
ocean power that did the research and
the project and other team members
supporting us and if you are more
interested in in in an NLP and
cybersecurity I encourage you to go to
Zanna talk tomorrow at 12 okay so if
there are any questions I'm happy to us
[Applause]
when you train the outturn color how
important is it to clean the data first
from this anomalies so the outline color
wouldn't learn them or is the anomalies
so rare that they do not interrupt yeah
mmm but that's I don't know actually but
we believe that in this cyber security
context like hacker activity activities
doesn't happen often so it's like 1/2
million probably it's fine to have one
point that this up so like this point
could be malicious but it could be just
just accident of this outline color kind
of couldn't learn such pattern so so
it's we build we just put all the data
we had and the assumption is that of
course there will be some kind of
malicious or anomalous points there but
they just the imbalance is so huge that
we didn't care okay thank you
hi very nice talk have you thought about
visualization of explanation of anomaly
because you said you know workflow that
each animal he says is inspected by some
operator so that do they have received
any help from the model that justified
the score so mmm
from the model probably not but we'd
like this is a small piece of the
biggest system so it's let's say one in
Richmond and we say okay
this is an anomaly because there is
uncommon process chain more or less and
then they can like focus okay then what
was the path of the execution and try to
to check ok what was maybe what this
process actually did and then they can
investigate more and of course there are
other other events so they can get like
also like alarms from like I don't know
maybe somebody saved the file now this
is any unusual path or they created some
some registry rights that are not
typical for such a program and so on so
they they will have more more
information to put bigger picture
thank you very much
[Applause]